c'est un drame survenu la semaine
dernière à montauban avant midi de
retraités vont être violemment percuté
par une voiture alors qu'elle traversait
sur un passage piéton la conductrice une
femme âgée de 88 ans aujourd'hui mise en
examen pour homicide involontaire
si cet accident fait tant parler c'est
parce qu'il remet en doute la faculté
des seniors à pouvoir conduire avec les
mêmes réflexes que la plupart des
automobilistes la loi imposera tel un
jour une visite médicale aux conducteurs
seniors pour s'assurer qu'ils sont
toujours en état de conduire en toute
sécurité alors êtes vous favorable à un
âge limite du permis de conduire
[Musique]
alors gilles verdez c'est non pourquoi
conduire pour les personnes âgées
souvent c'est la seule manière d'être
encore autonome la seule manière d'aller
faire ses courses d'avoir une vie
sociale si on fixe un âge limite ça veut
dire que toutes les personnes au dessus
ne pourront plus avoir une vie avec
d'autres elles seront cantonnés à la
solitude ce serait terrible donc oui il
ya quelques drames quelques grammes de
trop mais surtout ne pas ne pas faire
une loi pour les empêcher de conduire
mais ce serait dramatique week-end mais
je comprends pas du tout cette histoire
d'âge limite on n'est pas du tout face
égaux face à la vieillesse face à à la
maladie et c'est donc à ce moment là on
fait un contrôle on a un certain âge on
fait une visite médicale et là on voit
si on est apte ou pas conduire par
contre c'est hyper important de mettre
ce contrôle médical dans le sens où
c'est vrai qu'il ya certaines personnes
âgées quand tu vois qu'elles peuvent pas
marcher ou qu'elle voit mal et c'est
comment tu peux te dire qu'elles peuvent
être à conduire au niveau des réflexes
au niveau de la fin annoncée on n'est
pas tous égaux face à ana à la
vieillesse donc je pense que c'est
important de ne pas interdire est pas
mettre un âge limite parce que là ce
serait vraiment mais dégueulasse pour
les personnes qui en sont capables mais
par contre m à un truc médicale ouais
c'est important vous vous dites oui oui
mais je comprends même pas qu'on se pose
la question les chiffres par en 2017 et
une 900 personnes de plus de 75 ans
impliqué dans des églises et des
accidents de la route c'est plus d'un
quart de la mortalité routière
effectivement il ya plein de pays ou à
partir de 65 ans 70 à 75 ans vous êtes
obligés de passer une visite médicale
sinon vous n'avez pas votre permis c'est
le cas en hollande en suisse dans plein
de pays donc c'est tout à fait normal
que cela
les empêche d'être à deux de conduire
mais tu souhaite qu'ils aient à partir
peut-être de 55 ans de maison ou 60 ans
musique médicale annuelle où on vérifie
tes réflexes ta vision tintin capacité à
conduire etc c'est ça les pays où ils
sont nés d'un nom mais dont on
n'interdit pas aux jambes alors
interdire banon mais si on peut pas on
peut pas enlever le permis
automatiquement à quelqu'un parce qu'il
a 70 ans c'est pas possible
non non non
c'est un bel exemple
grandir depuis cinquante ans alors je
vais vous expliquer effectivement il
faut un contrôle mais tu peux pas
empêcher le permis d'enlever tu peux pas
faire ça enlever le permis de conduire
qui que ce soit tu vois il faut donner
peut-être un âge limite 80 ans peut-être
à partir de 80 en faire un contrôle
ce drame est épouvantable évidemment
mais c'est 1,4 justement tu l'as dit
c'est un quart des incarcérés mais bien
sûr mais je sens une mort c'est déjà
trop moi je pense qu'à partir de 60 ans
il faut toute façon tous les ans
tous les hommes
[Musique]
c'est pas son émission
alors mais vous que jean decon renard
mais si je dis quelque chose mais bien
s'entendre sur les ans beinheim arrêter
tous les ans tu vas et tous les autres
60 ans tu vas aller chercher par une
visite médicale mais oui pourquoi on
allait arrêter ses 75 ans serait pisté
oui voilà on a
donné mois cyril numérique de 50 ans m'a
vu à baisser donc donc c'est un délit
[Applaudissements]
monopolisé par la parole on vous aime
beaucoup merci raymond non je pense
qu'il faut aller vers la visite médicale
alors peut-être tous les ans 75 ans et
peut-être une visite médicale tous les
deux ans comme il existe dans le nord
dans le permis poids lourds par exemple
moi je passe une visite médicale tous
les cinq ans tous les cinq ans je suis
allé faire une visite mixer labs cinq
jours
voir si tout va bien on refait un code
de la route et puis moi je pense qu'il
faut le faire on peut pas laisser des
personnes de 89 ans 90 ans on prendre la
route si elle arrive à peine à marcher
comme indiqué li mais on peut pas non
plus les coupes du monde c'est le seul
truc qu'ils ont d'aller faire des
courses de voir leurs enfants de sortir
sinon tu leur dis carrément balla
mauvais la personne la plus concernée
ici mais oui mais moi je mets oui et
pourtant la mort dans l'âme parce que
justement je suis et -4 permis langer
pas de permis à lors d'apparitions
[Rires]
que sa vie comme au 19ème siècle marque
pas de machine à laver g
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
stmicro j'ai pas d'ascenseur à la main
dans la baignoire
et à la bougie chez toi
métallos planète c'est l'exemple type à
l'habitat paris donc à passer
mais les gens qui sont en milieu en judo
alors dit nous pensons pas pesant mais
parce que justement je sais à quel point
les hommes c'est que c'est les gens qui
vieillissent se sont très attachés à ça
parce que c'est une indépendance comme
en province est très nécessaire et
justement les gens ne sont pas
raisonnables donc moi je pense qu'il
faut quand même mettre une limite même
si m6 aurait de 85 ans mais surtout
c'est le verrou des forêts et surtout
valérie n'a pas complètement tort parce
que c'était un homme de 45 ans que tout
commence à 10 mais je suis désolé
pas 10 à 60 chaque année tous les mecs
qui m'ont tous les tous les 50 la
tendance vient ainsi d'être assimilé les
verts voient comment ça
tu puisses valérie et daniel c'est
stupide
mais ça ça vient de france 3 c'est
dommage
routière était imputable aux personnes
âgées raw alors
castaldi sciences
et aient parlé au prince oui oui quand
on a son permis annulé avait fourni sur
ce sujet n'ont pas encore
annulé son permis ce qui m'est arrivé on
passe des tests de réflexes des textes
des tests de vue et alors qu'on est
combat vous l'avez jamais rue et
le test de réflexes et extrêmement
difficile et je suis pas sûr que si vous
êtes passé ce test a personne de crête
kwc adresse de réponse vous avez des
petits des petites lumières faut il
faudrait déjà que les pieds avec les
mains c'est super dur
mais c'est le même test confiée au
pilote de formule 1 pour la reste ans
devrait plutôt plutôt toi tu étais en
plus des logements mais lente et salades
ont été limogés ou moins tester la
vigilance des projets et 91 ans ça me
paraît très bien pour faire problème est
ailleurs au moins deux mois alors alors
oui qui n'a pas parlé sur suivi moi mais
c'est pas trés un truc genre a dit baba
je suis d'accord avec tout ce qu'a dit
kelly je trouve que l abri de ready mais
absolument tout bien dit moi je suis
pour un viseur évidemment une sorte de
visite médicale qui sera à partir de 75
ans chose que c'est bien c'est
raisonnable après il faut pas non plus
considérer que la vieillesse et déjà
hyper compliqué de vieillir donc on peut
pas condamner les gens une deuxième fois
en gros voilà le naufrage de la
vieillesse et en plus vous n'avez pas le
droit de conduire donc ça ce serait
insupportable donc juste une visible
pour voilà pour la vue pour l'audition
et pour les reflex sinon les laisser
tranquilles parce que globalement les
jeunes sont beaucoup plus dangereux
l'anc les yeux c'est sûr est que les
jeunes arrivent boivent ils prennent de
la drogue ils ont ils ont pour noms mais
son cas mais le carnet des accidents
sont dus à sa justement là des jeunes
qui ont des mauvaises j'aimerais bien
entretenu parce qu'ils n'ont pas
beaucoup d'oseille et avec des problèmes
de drogue et les problèmes d'alcool chez
tout le monde n'y a pas que l'on verra
ce qu'en pensent ses téléspectateurs
tiens
merci merci oui bah oui à 61 % voyez pas
non à 80